all right should we have a bye i'm not  looking forward to this here we go make  sure you get banana and mayo are you  ready let's do it okay  i mean i'm not even a massive banana  sandwich fan i like it with nutella i  love banana sandwiches get it all over  your face  i made sure i got a lot of  um  i hope banana sandwiches i don't like  that really i met a guy i'm a guy once  i was buying a car  it was a nissan  and the guy i bought it from at the at  the place the nissan place  had a banana sandwich every day of his  life for 35 years well i mean bananas  very good for you full of potassiums you  had told me the other day they're a  natural antidepressant is that right  [Music]  harmonize with me and hold me back all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl